welcome everybody i'm maury samuels the
director of the yale program for the
study of anti-semitism and it's my great
pleasure to welcome you here today to
our benjamin and barbara zucker lecture
series
today's speaker pierre biernbaum is
known to many of you from his various
visits to yale over the years
the leading modern jewish historian in
france pierre biernbaum is an emeritus
professor from the university of paris
one where he taught political sociology
while his early work focused mainly on
questions of democracy and political
elites his later work has studied modern
and especially modern french jewish
history in a comparative perspective
focusing especially on the way that
different paths of emancipation involve
different relationships between jews and
the state
an incredibly prolific scholar he's
written over 20 books many of which have
been translated into english and some of
them
by stanford published by stanford
university press
i obviously can't list them all here but
i'll cite just a few of his titles to
give you an idea of the range of
subjects he's worked on
the jews of the republic a political
history of state jews in france from
gombetta to vichy from 1996
geography of hope exile the
enlightenment disassimilation from 2008
the anti-semitic moment a tour of france
in 1898 which was published in 2011
a tale of ritual murder in the age of
louis xiv the trial of raphael levy 1669
published in 2012
and his leon bloom prime minister
socialist zionist was published in the
jewish lives series at yale university
press in 2015.
his talk today is drawn from his new
book which i have right here
at pittsburgh
so translated would be the tears of
history from kishniev to pittsburgh and
it was published by galimar this year
so let me just say a word about how
things will work and then we'll get
going um we can't see or hear the
audience so um but we do want to hear
from you uh in the q and a function so
please submit questions at any time
during the talk in the q a
section at the bottom of your screen
and i will ask them to professor
biernbaum after his talk um please don't
raise your hand or
say anything because we can't hear or
see you
um so i think that's about it and i will
now turn it over to pierre please join
me in welcoming pierre biernbaum
it's a pleasure to be able to speak to
you and to the audience at yale
and uh i'd like to thank you from the
bottom of my heart
so
let's jump to the the core of the
argument
let's look to begin with
at the american exceptionalism
since the beginning of the american
history
no one could witness
any crusades
pogroms
violent mob mobilization against jews
since the foundation of the united
states
no jews were ever killed
for being a jew
as the result of an antisemitic violence
until
1915
during the
famous leo frank case
more than 4 000 lynching of african
american occur
mostly at the end of the 19th century
native americans were almost
exterminated
sometimes italian or irish were also
killed
as a result of a protestant catholic
violence
but jews
never face
a strongly organized anti-semitic
mobilization
until the 1930s
until recently
since the constitution of 1785 sc 87
and his article 16 6
section 3
abolishing any religious test
for joining the
there was a kind of separation of church
and state
allowing jews
to enter
within the administration
and
allowing them to become full citizens
in reality they remain
far from the state
dominated by the wasp
the protestant elite
they were safe
in their environment
but they joined mostly the professions
and joining a quiet life
in their local communities
in their suburbs
they had no national power
and to use david bial image
they remains
at the periphery of the nation safe
far from the center
from john higgm
to azaria diner
most american historians
outlined the marginal dimension of
anti-semitism in the u.s
one could not find a crucial central
political
event link to any anti-semitic
mobilization
at least until the turn
of the 20th century
everyone remember washington's famous
speech
to the toro synagogue
jews should live in peace
in security
and
threatened by no one threatened by no
one
under their vine tree
using the bible metaphor that belongs to
miche iv
during those years
there was a kind of culturous imbues
between jews and the american who
escaped from english from the english
forum and went through the red sea ia
the atlantic ocean
we know that this vision could be seen
as naive
his sons in some states
jude could not join the administration
until almost the end of the 19th century
those states remaining christian
we know that until the 20th century they
were sometimes excluded from some hotels
clubs and seashore
that the general grant took a decision
excluding the jews
that there were an official quota
in the ivy league
exogamic wedding
were often condemned
a kind of social anti-semitism
was strongly filled by jews
you can find example
in the american literature
look for instance at henry james books
at
hohara
splendid book
the meeting in samara
in the context of 1930
where at the very beginning of his novel
a christian woman said loudly if a
jewish family is going to sit in our
streets
our children are going to speak with a
jewish accent
a book
in which one finds a lot of antisemitic
remarks
given by the inhabitants of the son of
the city
look at the recent book by joshua cohen
the netanyahu
in the context of the 60s this this time
how strong
are the prejudices against the only
jewish professor
appointed in an uptown
university suddenly he discovered that
he is seen mainly as being a jew
anti-semitism in the u.s
was mostly social
not political
raising no political violence within the
public's fair
the main idea of this presentation
is the following one
the state
being in my vocabulary weak
decentralized astoughville one's outline
jews remain
far from the center
far from the state
and we're almost never
the target
of any political anti-semitism
like in france
where on the contrary
being linked to a strong state
they were seen
as being in charge of the state
betraying
the catholic nation
and from the dreyfus affair to vichy and
so on
they were facing a strong political
anticipation nothing like that occurs in
the us
therefore
the lacrimal's vision of history
seems to be foreign to the american
history
the u.s is a perfect example against his
vision
implying that jews always suffer
wear kill
chases and torture
in his famous article published in
menorah
in 1928
salo baron
soon to be appointed as the first jewish
professor at columbia university
saw that jews did not suffer
during the middle ages
that it was a period of relative freedom
compared to the painful life of most
peasants
jews could live a relative protected
collective and cultural life in their
ghetto
up to him
contrary to irish greats
and most jewish historians
the emancipation period celebrating the
french revolution
reason
and universalist values
could be seen as a period of suffering
different from the middle ages
later on
being the only historian speaking at the
iceman trail trial
baron thought
that modernity not the middle ages
brought despair and death
a time period when the state itself was
launching pogroms
and persecution
whether instead during the middle ages
no king ever initiated deliberately a
jewish persecution
the royal alliance studied later
by yosef yerushalmi
protecting the jews
even if this interpretation was denied
by fritz bear and other historians
if the king were often also active
during those antisemitic persecution
if the cruisers
were a crucial murdering period of
jewish history
it is nevertheless true that modernity
brought this persecution
at a new level
culminating with the russian pogroms
and
above all with the schwa
therefore
a lacrimal theory of history
seems to be
an appropriate vision
of modernity
if the showa gave a new legitimacy to
zlacrimone's vision of history
baron
now a full and celebrated professor at
colombia
saw the united states as the new middle
ages
a period
during which jews in their community
were having a peaceful life
in a kind of liberal empire
an empire different
from this despotic russian regime
but nevertheless in which a deep
collective jewish life
could flourish
the us
not old europe
should up to him
become the new center
of a lively jewish life
fearing no persecution
he created
a new school of jewish studies
focus on american jewish life
now at the core of jewish history
and it succeed
contrary to joseph yerushalmi
who was still a real european oriented
denying any values
the jewish american history
baron
born in krakow
and having study at vienna
became the new hero of the united states
pluralism
and decentralized society
praising its exceptionalism
without considering seriously
various signs of anti-semitism
even if he published some article
on this dimension
more or less
the contrast between the us
and the old europe
seems therefore to be meaningful
but baron
did not pay attention
to some crucial
events happening in the u.s
and i think
he never mentioned
the leo frank case
the little front case is the first sign
that something has changed
a kind of turning point
was happening when the first jew
was killed as a jew in 1915
hanged
and his body
severely
beaten
by some crowds of neighbours
of local notables
it was suddenly like if pogroms
were crossing the atlantic
only several only several years
after the kishnev pogrom of
1903
a massacre still
extremely present
in the remembrance of american jews who
recently immigrated to the u.s
kishnev in america
it looked like an oxymoron
the murder of leo frank could not be
compared
to the program of christianity
or of kiev
but nevertheless
this unprecedented killing in america
was such a shock
that it was seen as some kind of kitchen
of violence
occurring in the u.s
and kishin f will never disappear
from the jewish american consciousness
it's still the reference
the way
the lacrimal theory is felt in the u.s
transmitted dor le dor
from the generation to generation of
immigrant to another
from the turn of the 20th century up to
nowadays
this is a core of my argument
when leo frank a jew belonging to the
upper strata of atlanta society
was accused of abusing and killing a
young christian girl mary fagan
working in his factory
the myth of ritual murder had crossed
the atlantic
christian anti-semitism and anti-judaism
was for the first first time emerging in
the us
in this city so opened the jews since
centuries we all know the painful story
leading to frank hanging
condemned to death by local jury
surrounded by shouting anti-semitic
crowds
this decision
being confirmed by the supreme court of
georgia
and then by the supreme court of the
united states
without in fact any serious evidence
against him
he was nevertheless pardoned
pardoned by governor slayton
was seen immediately
as quotation
the kings of the jews betraying georgia
slatten
being now himself
surrounded by hostile crowds
trying to kill him
a local eduard remo the french
anti-semitic leader
the journalist watson
watson
published violent article
against the jews
telling his readers
that jews are threatening
the white christian society
with their financial power
his literature was exactly the same that
you that once you could find during in
france during the leader during the
refuse affair or during the vichy
the leon bloom period
his violence is amazing
in this newspaper of atlanta
i could give you references example but
let's save some time
during this short period
of violent anti-semitism
a parallel can be seen
between frank and refuse
whose prosecution occur
during the same period
for the first time
french
national
amer anti-semitism
and american
local
anti-semitism were quite close
both
drifus and france
are innocent
there was some strange similarity
during the prosecution like a similar
dictation test
governor slayton
can be compared to capitan picard
josef renak
to the lawyer louis marshall
lucille
to lucy and so on
but strong differences emerge
the strong french state
was able to protect drifus from the
crowds
and finally in 1906
dreyfus was recognized as being innocent
by the coup de casacion the highest
judicial court whether the local weak
state of georgia
was unable to protect france
an armed gun
of 150
local notables
invade his jail
took him and hang him
and at the end of the story
he was never recognized
as being innocent
he was pardoned he was burdened but not
even sometimes nowadays seen as innocent
in 1983
a man confessed that conley
a black american working in the factory
told him that he killed
mary fagan
immediately the kka
krokuk's club mobilized its member
at at the end a national commission
pardoned
nowadays
the discussion still goes
exchange of argument no one's
really know
[Music]
but what matters
is a memory of the front case
within jewish remembrance
even today
even today it's seen
at the local equivalent
of russian pogroms
and felt like the front case
was also remembered for instance
during the pittsburgh
synagogue shooting i could give you
example
where the reference
to
uh
to
[Music]
kishinov and to
leo francaise
are immediately
brought during the pittsburgh
shooting
the next step
bringing the lacrimos theory to the
united states
is the 1930
when roosevelt helped by some jews
from louis brandeis to felix frankfurter
from henry morgenthau to david legentau
help roosevelt
to build a partial strong state
able
to face the deep economic crisis
frankfurter was seen as a jew
controlling washington and the new deal
became the jew deal
a wave of political anti-semitism
spread
in the u.s
that can be compared to the drifus
or the contemporary leon bloom period
in france
during which thousands of antisemitic
militant shout deaths to the jews all
over france
like in france
for the first time in the u.s
a new political antisemitism raise as an
answer to the close relation between
some jews and the administration
the white shirt the khaki shirt the gray
shirt
recruited thousands of antisemitic
militants
galvanized by father coogling speeches
or by william pele
of franklin thompson declaration
against the jews in washington and
roosevelt
seen as a kosher president
the direct influence of nazism
and hitler mein kampf
was amazing in the u.s
and it will not disappear in the further
period
some years later on
jews were frightening by the lindbergh
presidential anti-semitic campaign
on which
phillip wrote
wrote his marvelous novel
ifantissimo's antisemitism did not
disappear
during the second world war
seen by someone as a jewish war
one must remember
that as soon as 1958
bombs
were sent
to the atlanta synagogue
to
benevolent congregation
from atlanta to atlanta
but everything was different
this time
social anti-semitism
anti-judaism
was now replaced
by political anti-semitism
spreading to the center
of the united states
in the main city of this nation it will
never be stopped
from atlanta to pittsburgh
through many important cities
from the east coast to the west coast
the alt-right
still sharing mineconf logic
launch bombs
against many jewish institutions
and kill some jews
in 1977
paul franklin influenced by hitler
launched some bombs
on the san luis
synagogue
and he said the following
sentences
the only thing i regret
the only thing that hitler didn't do
the only thing which is pity
which is a pity is that hitler did not
really
murder
6 million jews
he should have killed all of them
in 1978 william perth published his
famous
turner diaries a book which is more or
less forbidden even in the united states
an ukrainian
and ukrainian
influencing a large number of members of
the alt-right
still shown openly
during the capital coup
in washington
i could give you references by forget it
time is running quickly
in january
1981
alan berg
is killed by members of the aryan nation
in denver
in april 1986
neil rosenberg
is killed
at the cole torah institution study at
pittsburgh already
obviously
some violent anticipated actions
were linked to the nation of islam
or to the middle east evens
but most of them most of them are done
by members
of the extremist
alt-right
still influenced by hitler thought
between 1994
and 1999
30 jewish institutions
were attacked
by member of the alt-right
from san luis san luis
to los angeles
or pittsburgh or chicago
in 2000
members of the falk's front
shot
richard bomhammers at pittsburgh again
in 19205
a member of the aryan nation
sent a bomb to the oklahoma oklahoma
synagogue and so on and so on
in january 2009
the election of obama
gave a new strength
to the white extremists
like roosevelt
obama was seen by them
as a slave of the jews
an antisemitic propane propaganda flow
all over the country
more than seven thousand antisemitic
incidents
occur
during the obama
presidency
in april
2014
glenn miller jr shouting hail hitler
attack the overland park jewish
community
located in kansas
he was a member
of the national
socialist party of america
and
let's
look
at his
declaration
up to him
obama is a new rothschild
the cabal
is ruling america killing america
the talmudists are running
wall street
and so on and so forth
almost after trump victory on november
21
2016
neo nazi
almost the same day
november 21
20 november 21 2016
new nazi gather at washington
and shout hi hitler hi hitler hi hitler
gave the kicks
amazing
then
august
2017
charlottesville
the cuckoo's clown
the christian identity the proud boys
the vanguard america
the confederate white knights
the white live matters partisans
shouting
you will
never replace
us the slogan imaginated by the french
renault camille
or shouting blood and soil
raising flags
on which figure the swastika
a turning point
in american history
a moment of extremist fury
leading directly
to pittsburgh killing in october 2018
at the tree of life synagogue
robert bowers the killer
is a member of the white supremacist
11 members of the synagogue were killed
much more than in france during the same
period
several others
were severally
hurted
something
unpredicted
had occurred
in the united states
thus
are we watching
the end of american exceptionalism
the end of salo baron dream
immediately kissing f memory
resurface
the kishin of pogrom sung
by bialik
his famous poetry
has been transmitted from one generation
of russian immigrants
to another generation till nowadays
most american jewish writers
dealt with kishinev in their novels
from abraham kahn
to fill approach
from henry road
to seoul below
from malamud
to lamet shapiro
kishinaf is mentioned
and described
by some crucial characters
of their novels
after the pittsburgh massacre
after the pittsburgh massacre
let's quote what matthew friedman an
american historian said
we said kadish
for the dead people of babiyar
of kishnev
of was book mains and york
and for so many
awful things which happened since 2000
years
that but nowadays
nowadays it's different
kishin if it was in 1903.
barbie yar it was in 1941
this time
it's pittsburgh
in the united states
of america
in the 21
century we thought
it will never be back it will never
come back it will never
be like that again
it was a liar
we didn't know it
and so on and so forth
so you do see how strong
the remembrance of kishnev
is still
during those very recent years
in the piece in the pittsburgh massacre
context
kishnev is mentioned
by many commentators by many journalists
it was like if the pogromist
had reached
america
and then
it never stops
in april
2019
timothy earnest influenced again
still
by the turner diaries attack
the power synagogue
near san diego
killing a woman
and hurting the rabbi
and other members in november
2019
rich ulcerus
carrying mineconf again always mankind
at mankum in the united states amazing
attack the pueblo synagogue
telling the police quotation
i would have been happy
if the holocaust would have been an
entire reality they must all die
then the story
is known
and we are very close
to the conclusion
of this talk
after biden
victory on january 6
2021
is the capital coup
initiated again
by the same antisemitic members of the
alt-right
the white nazi supremacists the proud
boys the host keepers
showing openly the turner diaries again
and wearing t-shirts
on which it was written
6 million was not enough
then
is it the end of american exceptionalism
when jews are becoming a central target
within the political system
when
like in france
or during the weimar republic
they have access to the state
administration
as a result
a violent political anti-semitism can be
seen
when one noticed
that for the first time in american
history
many jews
were appointed by joe biden in his
cabinet
as secretary of treasury
at the state department
at the department of justice
at the security or even at the cia
one can guess
unfortunately
that a new wave
of a political anticipated anti-semitism
will give
some kind
of legitimacy
to the lacrimal theory
within the united states
thank you
thank you uh pierre um
for the really
interesting uh
talk so we have um
uh about 20 minutes for questions and i
ask um people to submit questions in the
q a i'll get us started uh and then
we'll be happy to ask um the audience's
questions
um
so first of all it's just so interesting
for us to have a french person
uh
view what's you know american history
and um
the especially the history of american
anti-semitism it's it's a fascinating
perspective especially for me as someone
who uh an american who works on france
but i'm interested first of all just in
a
somewhat personal question but what
motivated you to write this book now
um why did you decide to write about
american anti-semitism in this moment
today
i have no
real answer
in a way this book is following the
previous one
the one which was called le dumason a
comparing between france and the united
states
but mainly on the on the legal system on
the
supreme court and the kodak assassin in
france
and as you know
historians are always influenced by
the kind of issues they are facing
themselves in their
period of time
living so obviously what was occurring
in the united states
brought me
maybe brought me
to this issue in which in fact i was
working since many years in fact since
many years i've been working on salo
baron
and lacrimos theory
is this book
the contract for this book was signed
maybe 10 years ago 12 years ago so
before
galimar was kind enough to wait
because i couldn't find
any
meaningful material
to discuss salo baron
logic of history
and i've been looking at different
issues
colonial history many many different
issues
and suddenly the united states case
was fitting quite nicely
it gave me a kind of opportunity
to complete this book
and to
face
this uh extremely
strange
very meaningful very interesting
controversy
launched by salo baron in 1928 which was
it was a like a turn
like
something so important such a shock
within american within
all for all jewish historians something
completely
that couldn't be understood
so
i really wanted to go back to this
controversy for many years
and suddenly let's say
during the
2000 and i don't know 15 16
i found the american case something
which could be uh
an interesting way to deal
with
this salo baron
interrogation
yeah um and you know i would just point
out that um solo barone's family has
endowed our um research grants uh
yeah very nice so so you lay out in your
book and and in your talk a kind of
implicit comparison i would say between
france and the united states so you have
the french model which is a strong state
but a relatively weak communal form of
jewish life but jews have are kind of at
the center of state power at least after
a certain point in the 19th century
contrasted with the united states with a
weak state
robust communal jewish life
but jews are for the most part um
removed from political power until
relatively recently so my question is
which model do you think is better for
the jews in that time ah
in my book i quote
a very interesting
sentence by stansfield i know if you
notice this at the end of the book
in which he said
jews should never be the first in the
political system jews should never
appear
as a central figure jews should remain
at the local level
it's a crucial question
and
as a lover of the state
it's different it's difficult for me to
say that this is a worse solution
because it is true that
the closest they are to the state
the stronger they are becoming a target
the stronger anticipation let's look at
hitler himself
you cannot understand hitler
without
jews entering within the state during
the weimar republic
the crucial question for hitler
was to destroy the prussian state
this prussian state would have became a
jewish state
so you see the relation it's awful this
kind of relation between the state which
liberate the jews emancipate them
and the
negative consequence
against them
on the other side when jews
are remaining peacefully
at the periphery nothing like that occur
they remain at the periphery they are in
a way outside history
they have they are leaving their suburbs
a nice quite collective
life
but
maybe something nevertheless is missing
in their
in their
action
in their presence within their own
society
so the forest they remain outside
the center of society
by many aspects they
they are
like if they didn't really belong to
this society
[Music]
i don't know it's they are i mean and
it's my main question yeah and you treat
it's very interesting because at the end
of your talk and at the end of the book
you showed that you know really since
roosevelt but especially under biden now
they're really you know we we have the
kind of
equivalent of what you call the state
jews in france we have many jews that
really the center of the administration
and so according to your theory i mean
it might that might be
i hope my theory is wrong right right
okay so here's a question from the
audience and it's something that you
talk a lot about in your book but didn't
come up in the talk and i was wondering
if you could say a little bit more
about um the role of um anti-black
prejudice in the united states and its
relationship to anti-semitism this is
something that comes up a lot in your
book and how
the whole you know
problem of you know from slavery on here
affects the way that jews are seen um or
the relationship
between anti-black prejudice and
anti-semitism
well um
it's quite obvious that
black americans are really
the target
of prejudices
in the united states not the jews
and black americans were killed so many
of them and still are killed so many of
them
not the jews
but there is another question is
is there kind of
black american anti-semitism killing the
jews
and as i say sometimes it is
too much outline
there is a literature
in the uh
black americans and black panthers and
so on which was quite anti-semitic
there is a black american literature
which which has some antisemitic
dimension
i want i once
met
malcolm x
in paris
and he was in in a private
unknown meeting
far from any
control
and he was really
having some very strange sentences on
this dimension but
in fact if you
quantify if you look at the numbers
there were very few jews
there were some who were killed
by black americans
very few in fact
most of them and i discussed this in the
book
most of them the large
majority were killed by
white extremist
white
radical
nazi
white protestant
christian uh
members
uh
members of cuckoo's clan
and so on so i don't know if i really
answer yeah i mean i was i was kind of i
thought you would maybe say something as
you do in your book about how in a sense
um
you know especially in the south in the
american south but in the north too the
the kind of
greater prejudice against black people
in a sense um lessened maybe the
prejudice against jews i mean it's sort
of an obvious point it's like argues
yeah but another question that's a few
yeah let me add some short remark yeah
which which what is really remarkable
is what occurred during the little frank
case
because
conley was there he was a black american
there was a black american
and really
it it did look as
the one who did the murder he was there
discover mary fagan he brought her body
he would he really could have been
the murderer there were a lot of
arguments
he wrote any
consciousness he said that he wrote
these very strange
sentences which was found
on the side of mary fagan by the dead
body he wrote it
he he said it because there was a lot of
evidence that he might have been the
killer
but the jury
and it was a time in which lynching of
black american lynching occur a lot
so why is it that
the jury
and the people the notables
wanted
leo frank the jew
to be
the killer this is a very intriguing
case i cannot really answer
but this is a quite interesting case
which is going
against
the main logic
so jews are nice men and black americans
are the bad one yeah it's very very
interesting so here's a question that
several people have asked um and i it
was a question i had too
um it seems from your talk but also i
would say in the book that you mainly
identify
the threat the anti-semitic threat
facing jews to be coming from the right
or from the alt-right
but what about um
you know
what they call the new anti-semitism or
anti-zionism
uh where does that fit into your picture
um do you not see that as
as great a threat as the anti-semitism
from the right
i'm really sorry but it doesn't fit
my uh
my study doesn't fit at all
anti-zionist never kill a jew
i'm really sorry
the
members of the extreme left
and are not really extreme in the united
states
never kill a jew in the united states
they may write
arguments against israel
they may be critical of jewish ritual
they may be
hurting jewish
feelings of jewish
student at the university
they may be acting wrongly against them
but they never kill anyone
right although the recent attack on the
synagogue in texas i think was by
someone who came from the uk but i think
i think that was an anti-zionist um he
didn't kill anyone thank god but i think
but i i take your i take your point i
don't know
um i take your point so um
what about um
uh
different kinds of
jewish opposition to anti-semitism and
you show in your book that it was really
kishnyev that really um created the
first you know the american jewish um
committee you know so could you talk a
little bit about the role of
jewish opposition to anti-semitism and
whether you think um
you know i would say in the past but
also in our current moment and whether
um you think that um
you know now that jews do have more
power than they did at the beginning of
the 20th century um do you think they
should be doing something else something
different
i'm com i confess that i have no idea
i don't i really don't know
how they will be able to face what's
coming i'm afraid
that something worse could come very
easily
if um
if biden
[Music]
would would be losing the power or
if anything
would happen
i'm really scared about what could
happen
and
it's quite uh
painful
when you see that
nowadays so many jewish institutions in
america
are going to protect themselves like in
france
building
walls big walls big walls are not only
built in israel
but they are
being built
protecting jewish institutions
all over the french territory and they
are nowadays being built
in many
jewish institutions in the united states
it gave
jews
a kind of of being potentially
threatened by
some
degree of violence
they never faced before
and i really don't know
what could be done to protect them
in
this
society in which
the state administration is
not really a strong organized
centralized state
uh
i'm worried
um
okay yeah uh
so if you could talk a little bit more
about um this concept which was key i
think to your talk about american
exceptionalism
and is
american exceptionalism does that
concept only really refer to
the lack of anti-semitism in the united
states or do you think there are other
forms of american exceptionalism in
regard to jews
are there other aspects of american
jewish history that are exceptional or
is the is the whole concept of american
exceptionalism
false and we should just do away with it
it might become
false
but
during the 18th century
mainly the 19th century it was not false
at all
jews had a peaceful life in a
decentralized
society in which a state was not
threatening them and
in which no one was threatening them in
fact
so
i think that
at the core of jewry of american history
is the notion of pluralism
which will be
which will become later on
multiculturalism
from pluralism to multiculturalism
nowadays
hyphenate a society
the famous hyphenated society from
horace callen
to michael walter
give the jews like to other minorities
a strong legitimacy
to live
peacefully
having
many dimensions of the within their
identities
it is at the core of american
exceptionalism the idea of hyphenated
society pluralism
sharing many identities being both irish
and american chinese and american
unfortunately maybe not japanese and
american
it's really at the core of american
exceptionalism both the notion of
pluralism
the notion of decentralization
and of hyphenated
identity
which allow jews
to be in favor of israel also openly
without hiding themselves in france it's
becoming something
which can be stayed openly but
will it be some strong consequences in
fact as you know
as much as i do in the 19th century the
french israelites
were never zionists whether in the
united states
look at louis bandai's brandeis
louis brandeis was at the top of the
supreme court
and he was leading at the same time
the zionist organization of america
unbelievable in france
unbelievable in france you couldn't be
openly having such an important function
in the zionist
institution and being at the same time
at the highest level
of the judicial system so there is a
specificity
okay so maybe last question here if you
could just say a few remarks um about uh
well to compare
the the um situation facing jews in
france and america today so the the
anti-semitism in france versus the
anti-semitism in america if you could if
you had any thoughts about um the
threats that jews face
um in the two countries are they similar
or different threats well as you know in
france
they are facing both
the extreme right anti-semitism which is
extremely strong
and unfortunately there is a strong
anti-semitism
some
parts of the muslim
of muslim citizens in france some of
them are sharing
france is closer to the middle east
france has a lot of immigrants coming
from the middle east from algeria
a society which was which is still more
or less in war with israel
so there is this kind of middle east
aspect not iraq and not iran but middle
east
which is much more present
at the core of the french society
there is also a new aspect which is
linked to this middle east question
[Music]
is the fact that jews in france are more
and more
israelization themselves
they are
they've got a lot of families in israel
when someone is interviewing israel
when there is something happening in
israel a french journalist will go there
and ask someone
what's happening and the guy is going to
to answer in front in french
you will find thousands of french jews
speaking french in
israel
so the french journalist will ask them
in french
what's happening and the guy will answer
in front of
is there any kind of confusion between
israel
and the french jews there are more and
more involved within the french within
the israeli
history they eat israeli food they sing
israeli songs they read
french israeli newspaper or english
israeli newspaper
they follow day by day what's happening
there
they dance with the music coming from
israel
which is not the case in the united
states
as you know
american jews are to the contrary
going far more and more far from the
israeli
situation most of them never went to
israel
in france most jews
went several times in israel there is a
strong difference
between the
two countries yeah
okay well that i think brings us to the
end i feel like we could uh keep talking
all night but that brings us to the end
of um
our session today but let's hope last
question is um what about the english
translation of this book will it be
translated into english
more it's up to you
the audience
that will be really nice and i would be
very sorry if it's not translated yeah
so would i it's a it's such a
fascinating uh book you're kind of
updating toqville
you know as you say took ville did was
not interested in jews and you're kind
of adding that dimension so
you took deal and you should take care
of that and okay i'll translate it in on
my spare time okay well so thank you uh
pierre so much and i'm sorry you can't
hear everyone but i will clap for
everybody in the audience and thank you
all for coming i urge everybody to
please sign up for the yipsa ypsa
mailing list so you can find out about
our other talks we have a bunch of other
interesting talks planned for uh this
semester and i look forward uh to seeing
uh you all at them soon and thank you
again to pierre